Jimmy's got rage candy make something
happen with it great time is blocked
alright nowhere right now it's not over
just yet with the little bear Jimmy's
Daniel I'm fighting back well you got a
touch nothing go for it
oh my god down the light when Jimmy get
led one lock and you can still get the
round and the game and the set
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right folks we're about to get
started here here we go let's give it up
Maria
nothing but CEO says number one bright
where everybody watching naps on player
one neon play those who do key gets a
tech good block by name appropriate
punished by me
[Music]
get the combo let's go to look for
loyalty gets it
seven seconds to go don't we
Oh God asleep on the competition stop
looking at me doubled Astrid it won
again big elbow drop in one of his best
men you know I like the PC but you know
with you a lot of these exchanges st. is
coming out on top because he's getting a
lot of the little boats in there Brian I
feel like doesn't have that freedom
switch to another each other
[Music]
[Applause]
who's gonna get this here we go he's
going in no he wants to mix up anybody's
man Jimmy Jimmy J grant is going to the
top of the Tekken world tour
[Music]
the story is really close to crying
y'all hate there all you want I should
come out what hey I give me that devil
gene and left about rain clothes well
unfortunate circumstance for James er
now is that the wrinkle he'll be happy
Oh
loses to rock this p.m. Albania
let's work another raping the wall oh
the duck for the flat del boy in big
trouble year
[Applause]
congratulations to these second place
you have heckling box seats
[Applause]
I mean when you when you talk about
Brian fury everyone knows I mean you
know me is the guy me is the guy that
put really Brian on the map but I feel
like the baton pass went Jimmy J Tran
and Jimmy G Tran has been just you know
D Brian player I would say over the past
few iterations you know he's the Brian
player because he ends rounds with Mach
breaker when he can yeah he doesn't just
go for like that normal or he just
doesn't like D like all right well I'm
just gonna do this basic no he ends it
with Mach breaker if he cans he ends it
with Mach kick he doesn't with the cool
Brian moves when he can
and the Crowder's away
marry me jack
[Music]
yeah I'm sure you're gonna have a lot of
fun getting your characters warmed up
and stuff so yeah I think that's it
below maybe for the stream knee will we
see some Brian today I want you to Brian
we didn't tip all right all right so
we're going to a short break guys
you
you
this is the showcase at the crowd and
cheering already Brian mirror this is
gonna hug yet so high let's get hi
people
Bryan versus Bryan no walls for the
first game let's do this
Rockne vs Jimmy trend wrong one
[Music]
my days I think of message right now in
round one
[Music]
[Music]
Brian Goths going at it saying no they
are indeed here out in the cold snow
disciple Wow
it kicks in a row it's a kickoff
[Music]
wall there
[Music]
and he's so dominant with the cause all
the time you return the favor
Jimmy no forcing me back one contrast to
the next walls Berkeley is dead to the
other
trying to take this back now
counting it
don't the company educate all right
still
call it
they're trying to space make its
underwear
Dubey they found with the pressure level
yes rage careful
that's great tribe
one is beautiful view yr it is again
dumping
he read this nugget in here
to the moon the ball look at the damage
now the tall
forty-four
make fried temple
we'll turn around after that blow crazy
these like crazy
into the wall we go
and the press are always right
[Music]
are this
[Music]
[Music]
Oh No
couple
why I read from Roxy go straight to
radar no funny business
go to the wall nope like me
we go look at the damage
there we go
waitwhat
[Music]
all
hundred
to the wall to sir
quite the Devon
Oh
[Music]
apparently find out
oh we get to this comes Jimmy true
looking for
orbital
you only went to toe job is it just shy
of the brainstem
takes it dbj Tran takers it's very white
everyone with you who gets the to this
resource markets yes
get the kickoff news that is
to the world never see this question but
is very clear in a second right
they're funded for the to the wall
it is everyone
go crazy and look at that couple made
with a pool
there's a counted
this came in
[Music]
so good he wants it man he walked it
wasn't a job to finish his basic right
though
there's actually another one
any thought for a jar and takes it three
games to all my day finishes the last
time three rounds to zero
gimme transluscent head and shake his
hand war showdown we have this witness
here with me versus Jimmy Tran two epic
players
[Music]
[Music]